all right you right wing maniacs it's
friday which means we've got another
panel extravaganza for ya i'm dave rubin
of course this is still the reuben
report and joining me today
are the hosts of the chad prather show
on blaze tv chad prather and the senior
columnist at townhall.com and author of
the brand spankin new book it came out
this week we'll be back the fall and
rise of america kurt schlichter guys
welcome to the reuben report
thanks for having me good to be with you
you know i normally do these friday
panel shows with
three guests but i felt that the egos
involved today we were gonna have to do
it with two so uh you guys gonna bring
it or what well actually chad's hat
counts as a guess
basically basically it is the third
person uh it's like john bolton's
mustache except headgear
very true plus chad has a dog there so
we'll see if we can make a guest
appearance uh okay so uh let's we're
gonna start we're gonna do the aoc thing
first no we're gonna do okay so we're
gonna talk about a couple things today
so we've got this ridiculous uh response
by aoc after comedian alex stein uh
mocked her booty over there at the
capitol we're going to talk about that a
little bit we're going to talk about
abide inflation which is now at 9.1
percent do you miss the orange man yet
uh and uh if you think that things have
been bad with biden well he's going to
get the boot it's pretty much obvious
that it's going to happen after the
midterms and i'm pretty sure gavin
newsom is going to somehow take over
although i'm not exactly sure how it's
going to happen we will get to all that
in just a moment let me real quick talk
to you guys about real estate agents i
trust you know buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be 10 times
worse if you're not working with the
right agent generally speaking our homes
are our biggest investment that's a ton
of responsibility and you need an agent
who takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my buddy glenn beck they work
with only the best agents in every
market they do their homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
their network and here's a big one they
only work with full-time pros no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
team makes the introduction and then
follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go to real estate agents itrust.com
today provide them with some basic info
they'll contact you and then you move
maybe to florida maybe to where chad is
in texas and uh probably not to where
kurt still lives in california but i
guess you never know uh okay let's start
with this uh aoc quote unquote attack
here is alex stein comedian and i guess
we can call him a rabble rouser on the
capital going after aoc
see my favorite big booty latina i love
you aoc you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty latina
i love it my favorite aoc nice to meet
you
okay so aoc heard him you know giving a
shout out to the booty she gave him the
peace sign clearly was not upset but
then later on when the video went viral
she realized he said the thing about
babies and abortion and then she got
very very upset and she issued this
response
he was engaged in very clearly sexually
threatening aggressive behavior
right in front on the capitol steps in
front of an officer and
he wasn't even asked to take a step back
like
this officer was just cool with it
okay so aoc doesn't like being harassed
except just a few days ago you guys
might remember that supreme court
justice brett kavanaugh had to leave a
morton's steakhouse in dc from the back
exit because a bunch of protesters were
out front here was aoc's tweet on that
she wrote poor guy he left before his
souffle because he decided half the
country should risk death if they have
an ectopic pregnancy within the wrong
state lines it's all very unfair to him
the least they could do is let him eat
cake uh kurt uh do you think that uh she
doesn't get irony or that they are the
ones who have unleashed this or there is
an inconsistency here etc
well just a little bit what i what i
really like it well first of all i think
it's time that we shout out the racism
of this anti-sir mix-a-lot agenda that
she's obviously embraced um i like big
butts and i cannot lie
yeah but you know she tries to deny and
uh i you know if alex wants to uh uh you
know call out uh you know her
uh amazing latina booty in his words uh
you know i i actually prefer a sleeker
latina booty but that's you know that's
that's my personal call
uh i i think it's interesting that she
redefines the rules of politics where
you're allowed to intimidate people to
gain a political effect but then she
wants to regulate that she's like you
can you could bother him at a steakhouse
but you can't talk about her ass
i i
i i i it's remarkable and i i just kind
of like scratched my head and said
who told you you get to decide all this
stuff
how about we'll do whatever we want
including you know talking about uh your
junk in the trunk
and you can shut up you
jibbering halfwit
because she's not a smart lady that's
you know that's not you know her brains
are not her biggest
ass fans if you get my drift kurt i did
say to my guys five minutes before the
show started we were going to be
demonetized on youtube just for me
saying your name and i'm sure that's
already happened so i'm glad you're here
my friend uh chad chad is the point here
with these guys uh that there's just no
level of irony they they simply don't
care if we expose them for saying you
can't protest these people
or you know you can't protest me but you
can protest these people or the tweets
she sent out that you may remember a
couple of weeks back that the point of
protest is to make people uncomfortable
but now of course she's the victim
well you know you can point out the
hypocrisy over and over again of of the
left and the progressives and the
wild-eyed woke um you know
you want you can't define a woman but
then men can't speak out about abortion
because they're not women you know and
then you go to this and
i don't think that aoc
uh
look she was a bartender she's used to
having cat calls i'm quite certain that
she did uh so this is but you know the
thing that's crazy about this is how
she's her big issue is more about the
capitol police officer who wasn't
defending her or something while her
boyfriend just walked the dog and walked
right on in um you know and let's talk
about you know the hypocrisy is one
thing and that people have to understand
that's what a guy like alex stein
who is a comedian he's a prankster
this is a guy who puts on a women's
swimsuit and trolls city council
meetings um he is a he is comedy's shock
jock he's a friend he's opened several
shows for me i have watched
conservatives in the audience sit there
with mouths a gate at the things that
come out of his brain
uh he wanted to do this he was trolling
the hypocrisy for this very reason i
texted him you know as soon as i saw the
video
and uh he said she walked right into my
trap and
you see the results of it
is there some kind of danger here like
joking aside that this is what politics
is devolving into i don't think that
alex stein started this stuff you know
we've shown the videos the compilations
on my show a million times maxine waters
get in their face and chuck schumer
there will be no peace and protests at
their houses etc etc so it's not about
who started this but is this just kurt
an unwinnable game even if we expose the
hypocrisy we mock the hell out of them
that eventually just every troll
everywhere will be following every
politician and every pundit and every
political person and that will all just
slowly be on that descent to hell
together
well look if you're going to choose the
lowest common denominator you got to be
prepared for the next guy who's got to
choose a even lower one
and uh there are a couple interesting
points here
that you brought up the the first is the
hypocrisy point
you know
dave chad me
we're all woke to this stuff we're
conservative woke we're used to it i
mean when when hunter biden comes out
you know and he's packing a pistol as
well as a handgun uh you know doing uh
uh blasting rails of coke awesome
latavian prostitutes behind uh we're all
kind of like ah you know if it were if
our don jr would be on the new york
times but it isn't we're used to the
hypocrisy normal people who do not do
politics 24 7 or not so pointing out the
hypocrisy has some use even if guys like
us are jaded
the other issue is and it's a much more
serious one which i cover in my book
there you go he's a pro
i'm i'm putting it out on the street on
it bring me my money guys um
if we
what they have done is people like aoc
are legitimizing the use of
non-political means to influence
politics that is instead of persuasion
and elections uh they they are using
intimidation now if you're supposed to
go getting kavanaugh's face
what's the moral guardrail that says you
can't slap his face and what's the moral
guardrail beyond that that says you
can't shoot him in the face and that's
not crazy talk because a guy came to a a
republican softball game and actually
shot people
so this is actually very dangerous but i
think it's more dangerous to them
because
you know
normal americans
conservative americans many of us have
military training many of us have not
grown up in a use your inside voice kind
of environment
uh have not gone to schools where if a
bully messes with you and you punch them
you both get both get suspended uh a lot
of us have been in fist fights
do they do the rules that these guys so
casually abandon are not there to
protect guys like us
here to protect them
because if we're in a situation where
power is to con
currency well you know
i know how to i know how to survive in
that kind of environment because i did
in the military
could they
so chad to that point
uh did you see her follow-up tweet where
basically she said that the reason she
approached him was because the police
officer was gonna do nothing so she was
gonna deck him those were her words she
was gonna deck him now it's obviously a
lie because she thought he was a fan and
that's why she flashed the the peace
sign and went in for the selfie it
wasn't until after when she realized but
just the fact that a democrat
congresswoman can say that she was going
to assault someone i'm pretty sure
that if ted cruz or rand paul or pick
your republican said they were gonna
deck someone for making fun of them
maybe that would make it to the new york
times you think
yeah i i texted alex this morning just
to ask if he was okay because obviously
he's on all the news junkets and they're
talking about him and alex is no
stranger to this this is what he wants i
said are you okay and he said man he
said i'm doing awesome he said actually
he said watch what happens aoc will be
the biggest victim of sexual harassment
i think she's well on her way in pushing
this thing uh yeah i tweeted last night
i said i wish aoc would have decked uh
alex stein because that can you imagine
the hilarity of the lawsuit that would
ensue from that
uh i just think that would be just
non-stop entertainment look and i agree
with kurt you know
i i think that you do fight fire with
fire sometimes it's necessary to get in
a very ugly way down in the weeds we
have devolved into a post-critical
thinking
society uh we don't do that anymore we
think in terms of
quick snippets 15 second blocks
and uh our our concentration level
doesn't doesn't hold dialogue and it
certainly certainly doesn't handle
debate we've become thin skinned we've
gotten a little crazy in our thinking
uh we've polarized our sides and and you
know look i live in the public eye dave
you as well you know you get on that
stage every now and then in front of
hundreds of thousands of people you know
you never know what element is there you
hear the horror stories of the crazed
people who bring a gun to a a live event
and do unthinkable things i travel with
an element of security i know you do too
you know you try to you try to think you
know not living with that reality or
that understanding but you have to keep
your head on a swivel because let's face
it everybody is looking for a fight
these days and social media has brought
it much more closer to our reality and
daily existence because that world's
gotten smaller let me ask you guys one
other thing as an offshoot of what chad
just said right there which is to me
there is no middle ground with these
people at this point i think kurt you've
been talking about this for a while uh
that they're like what is the middle
ground with aoc at this point regard you
know regarding how she feels about
america how she feels about truth and
biology and proper governance and all of
those things so what do we do about that
that you know this is not 20 years ago
when you could say i mean i was a
democrat 20 years ago but when there was
some agreement like oh america's decent
and let's debate the stuff
where now it's like there's really
nothing that we could offer them that
they would accept and be willing to do
the same on their side
look i'm a trial lawyer i go and
convince normal people uh to to
find in favor of my clients and i use
facts and evidence i but i i i don't
advocate doing that against people like
aoc once again all in my book we'll be
back
of america um
you can't argue with them because
their their premise is completely
different their premise is all about
personal power their power their
position uh and their profitability so
you're not going to talk them out of
anything as i say in the book there's no
bottom date there's no point where they
look at and go like the rulers of
venezuela they have their their people
are breaking into the zoos to eat the
zebras because they have no meat now if
you care anything about good governance
or helping your people you say my gosh
my policies have led to people eating
the zebras i had better change course
but that never happens there's no bottom
because it's not about the people it's
about the pat maintaining the power and
position and it's the same with them so
i don't propose we debate them i don't
propose we reason with them we we save
that for normal people who aren't really
aware of politics all the time and need
to be brought over to us and it does
work we we've seen that with our latinx
friends are now 50
republican because we've convinced them
uh we just have to defeat people like
aoc we have to crush them electorally
and we have to crush them culturally so
i'm not here to win them over i'm here
to win over them
chad bring us home on this one do you
agree with that
yeah i do agree with that i think it's
sad boys into some other topics we're
heading towards look the results will
actually turn people's mind towards the
way that i think we're going to see it
go uh and bring around some some values
that we hold dear and i think have been
tried and true and tested and have
worked and brought great results we
understand that the progressive
ideologies whether it's the green new
deal or modern monetary theory or esg
scores they're not going to work they're
they're a failed system and as kurt
referred to venezuela that's the goal
these people want deficit they want debt
they want starvation they want less
population they want less fossil fuels
these are not ideologies that are going
to work in the long run they are failed
policies
and uh they are held in the minds of
insane people like aoc look the pendulum
has pushed so far to the left in regards
to the progressives that even the
democratic party does not like or want
aoc in their ranks so i agree you know
we almost have to take a a breitbart
type attitude of war and say we're going
to bring the fight to you we're going
we're going to use not only logic and
debate but we're not interested in
arguing with you for the sake of arguing
we're going to show you the results and
the deal is the numbers simply do not
lie and we're seeing that happen played
out right here in front of our eyes
right now yeah well we're seeing it
certainly happen where i'm at right now
in florida which is we've got a guy in
office who's laying up some some
seriously sane policies and now it's
being reflected clearly in the polls and
obviously desantis is going to crush it
in november but you gave me a good segue
with all the stuff that ain't working
these days uh nothing's working with
this administration inflation now 9.1
that's at least what they're telling us
which most likely means it's worse than
that and you know when cnn is covering
it then something really ain't right
horrible news for your wallet new data
today released by the biden
administration shows inflation surging
to 9.1 percent that is the highest level
in more than 40 years and it means the
prices we pay overall are 9.1 percent
higher than they were at this time last
year so unless
you have benefited from an unlikely 10
percent raise since then
you now have less money in your pocket
than you did a year ago
much of the increase is driven by gas
prices which we should note have fallen
in recent weeks but they remain insanely
high up nearly 60 percent in this report
and the increases are felt across a
range of categories prices on groceries
are up more than ten percent housing
nearly six percent
today president biden admitting that
inflation is still quote unacceptably
high vice president harris saying there
is no question we still have work to do
little consolation to the millions of
americans who are struggling to make
ends meet due to
rising prices across the board
chad i'm not a math a magician over here
but uh
is it crazy to say that if you print a
whole bunch of money based in nothing
and you just keep printing it that you
might devalue the existing money because
then there's suddenly more of it and i
have some recollection of something
called supply and demand i don't want to
confuse people on a friday but do you
think that maybe they did this
you know i've said for for a while now
that this is the controlled crash of the
plane they're bringing it down they
intend to crash it they want to survive
it themselves but
what they're doing in terms of creating
as i alluded to earlier this adherence
to a modern monetary theory where
deficits and debt are a good thing if
you go back you look at the green new
deal when the green new deal first came
out i thought it was something written
in crayons by a fifth grader i said
there's no way you can't do a 90
trillion dollar overhaul infrastructure
uh rebuild you can't you can't do all of
these things that you know they were
proposing that you want to do and then i
started realizing when it comes to
modern monetary theory they can do it
because you don't have to back up this
system uh you centralize everything you
devalue everything and we're starting to
see it play it out we're seeing it
played out in the stock market we're
seeing it played out in crypto
currencies everything is being brought
back to the feds and they're the ones
who are in control the ideologues on the
left the progressive wild eyes as i call
them you know the your billionaires your
gates your zuckerbergs your soros
they're the ones who are pulling the
strings whoever's pulling their strings
i don't know but these folks don't like
you they don't love you they want to see
this thing crash and america is has been
the bastion of of independence that has
stood in their way so we're a direct
target look we're headed towards barrels
of oil that'll be 300 325 a barrel uh
what are you gonna do when it's ten
dollars eleven dollars for for a gallon
of gas
they don't mind that because in the end
this is the result they're trying to
bring about
chad i appreciate your calm measured
answer there but i've got video right
here we're going to show you biden said
this is just temporary don't worry
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down
no one's talking about
this great great thing it's on highly
unlikely that it's going to be long-term
inflation
kurt you heard him no one's talking
about this great great you know
yet here we are
well i you know far be it for me to
criticize president cornholio but
uh this
you know i i
there there is something to be said to
uh the clown proven effect where you
where you let everything fall to pieces
so you can rebuild it in your own image
that happened when i was much younger uh
with jimmy carter running uh the united
states into the ground uh social a
politically militarily now
um
of course jimmy carter is the only one
happy about the biden presidency because
now he's not the worst president of the
last century
but we got reagan
and reagan showed us how to deal how to
deal with the soviets how to deal with
inflation
the the the fact that these guys are
driving us into the ground dave
is an opportunity we should never let a
crisis go to waste because they are
teaching us about the intellectual
bankruptcy of modern monetary thinking
they are teaching us uh the end game of
the climate change hoax they are get
they are going to run america into the
ground and we got two more years of this
that we may just win over a new
generation of americans now we're never
going to win over the uh chardonnay
swilling wine women of suburbia we're
not going to win them we're not going to
win the faculty lounge crew we're not
going to uh win over the activists but
you know we're we're winning over uh
latinx americans uh working class
americans
uh
it it's going to truly be a realignment
and you know if some idiot comes down
the road in 20 years and says there's
this thing called modern modern monetary
theory and we should spend everyone's
just gonna go shut up i lived through
9.1 inflation i gave 9.1 to the big guy
no thanks
chad is that the silver lining here that
you know in politics basically there
aren't that many people who are going to
vote differently but there does seem to
be
some sort of disaffected liberal some
sort of the old same liberal i know a
little something about it that is just
like man the democrats are completely
bananas and that might be the only crew
of people really willing to move it's
not going to be say the the chardonnay
suburban moms that char that kurt's
talking about they're not going to move
and the crazy woksters aren't going to
move but the average democrat who just
got mugged by lockdowns and the rest of
this insanity that is a person that
might move
well you know dave you're a perfect
example of that not only in your
migration politically but your migration
in your exodus from california look no
further than california to see what
these these ideas of bureaucracy lead
you to i don't know how anybody with
common sense remains in california these
days but yet you look at the stark
contrast of a place like florida where
you know ron desantis barely beat out
andrew gillum but because of old
leadership and great policy look how far
that expanse has separated the left from
the right and and florida has become a
golden state of redness uh and liberty
and freedom and success and opportunity
and many many people are coming there
texas in many ways the same way uh
although a little bit more on the bubble
but i will say that yes we you know
results will prove a lot of things look
at you know myra flores uh hispanic from
the grand valley in south texas look at
what's going on in the rio grande valley
in texas um you know i i love what kurt
said because i tend to agree with him i
can almost if i was painting the future
being prophetic i would say you know i i
would like to see ron desantis ride in
on a white horse in 2024 and and see a
revolutionary change that comes back in
the days of
you know ronald reagan's 1980 uh you
know inauguration it's and i think we
can bring that back if we have the right
people with the right policies it feels
like that's the hope that's the move
here and it's just like man how much
damage can they do in the you know
remaining two and a half years that this
guy's got if i mean i think they're
going to get rid of him right after the
the midterms what they need a scapegoat
and they'll just take him out because
they're stringing him along everyone
gets that something ain't right and
speaking of something not being right he
is in the middle east right now that's
right mr magu landed in israel yesterday
and uh well here's we could have picked
many videos but we have limited time
here's just one of the incredible
moments of your president joe biden
today
okay so once again he shook nobody's
hand he then walks over and he's being
led by like grandpa uh we could have
shown you the video of him saying that
we must honor the holocaust uh he meant
to say the horror of the holocaust
generally in israel you don't say you
want to honor the holocaust that's
something they're a little touchy about
uh kurt
it's not going well for this guy and
they can't hide it much longer
well here's the problem dave this guy
started it as a baseline [ __ ] uh sure
he's corrupt sure he's kind of a pervert
but he was always stupid and now you you
sent it to the 10th power by him being
senile
and
i i i'm wondering who's in charge
because it's not him maybe it's dr jill
uh she of the breakfast tacos
i just
i think it's hysterical that they went
all in on this guy and they own him so
completely because they so
differentiated him from donald trump so
before we had mean tweets but we had you
know peace we had cheap gas we didn't
have giant you know inflation
and this guy is so
you know discredited the brand that
they're going to actually have to turn
on him in the harshest way to uh put
space between themselves and uh whatever
progressive nitwit follows whether it's
uh you know governor hairstyle or big
chief warren or
gosh i hope camella
they've really put themselves in a tough
place
but
the scary thing is he's got two more
years almost two and a half and there's
a lot of damage you can do to the united
states if i was america's enemy
i would think about acting in the next
two years if i was taiwan let me put
this way i i i'd be shorting taiwan
right about
we'll get to governor hairstyle in just
a sec but uh
so ridiculous chad as you were talking
about sort of a controlled demolition
before isn't biden sort of the perfect
person you would want if you were trying
to do a controlled demolition because
he's a total 47-year in-government swamp
creature he was never that bright to
begin with he's taken every side of
every issue and now because of the
cognitive stuff it's like he will say
literally anything they put in front of
him including repeat the line
dave he's the perfect guy for this
situation look
you got you got a guy that you can
completely control he doesn't know what
planet he's on he doesn't know what room
he's in he doesn't know what he's eating
at any given time he doesn't know where
he is
they know that you can't invoke the 25th
amendment on this guy because if if you
don't have let's go brandon you get
let's blow brandon
you got president
versus vice president knee pads what are
you gonna do so so here's the thing
they know that it's the perfect guy that
no one wants kamala harris they know
that they've got him over the barrel
because if they really wanted to they
could use this hunter biden nonsense oh
yeah re-troy not only him but his legacy
and his memory forever you got a
president talking about temporary and
transitory inflation here's a guy who's
been in washington dc for 50 years he
doesn't know anything about temporary
uh
this guy he's straight up lying to you
they're telling him what to say and he's
going to say it no one can get rid of
him because of what you would get next
who do you want president pelosi hell no
hell no
well
whoever's pulling the strings that's
that's what you've got he is the perfect
guy they know they've got him under
control and as i do believe as i'm sure
you guys agree you know
uh governor hairstyle was at the white
house yesterday meeting with dr jill for
whatever god knows god knows reason
that's the guy they're going to trot out
after these midterms you'll see it
happen it'll be a quick transition so
let's show let's show some video of that
because this is really an extraordinary
moment the president
leaves the country he is thousands and
thousands of miles away on the other
side of the earth and then who shows up
at the white house to meet with his wife
and the pres the vice president
how you feeling
yesterday we're on hand exclusively as
governor gavin newsom enters the west
wing of the white house amid speculation
about his political future during this
trip newsom is meeting with vice
president kamala harris white house
chief of staff ron klain and first lady
dr jill biden what is the message that
you're trying to convey to
jill biden today to vice president to
leaders on the hill have your back have
your back
he is such a slimy
smarmy
inauthentic
soulless i really believe he is soulless
i do not think he has a human soul he
has wrecked originally he wrecked san
francisco as the mayor then he wrecked
california as the governor but just in
terms of the optics alone they knew what
they were doing dr jill who clearly has
not examined joe she knew exactly what
she was doing by having that guy show up
to the white house kamala knew exactly
what they were doing joe's not not here
let's get this guy in i mean that's the
plan right kurt like how are they going
to do this thing they're going to get
him to step down she'll jump in as as
president for a little bit they'll get
him as vp nancy will be upset because
she's not and then they'll get kamala to
step down and then he jumps in at 24
like what are they doing here oh well
look i i i think that's a good
explanation for him going to washington
and playing doctor with jill
[Laughter]
i mean he he is a smarmy weasel but i i
just
i i find it
amusing that blue america
the little ruling class thinks that the
rest of america the ones that actually
vote
are are going to want to turn their
their state into another california okay
it used to be you know california used
to be the land of swing palm trees and
opportunity i got there with uh when uh
uh governor reagan was in charge and i i
was able to you know make all my dreams
come true if you want to use a hack
cliche but it's it's a fact and now it's
about uh hobos dropping their used
dinner on the sidewalk and having to
play hopscotch and avoid being impaled
by hypodermic needles i i
you know
one of the other problems for gavin
newsom besides the fact that he's got
the albatross that is having turned
match to turn a great state like
california into a hell hole
is he's really going to have to trash
joe by
hard
to to differentiate himself and i think
that's going to alienate some of the
democrats i like the democrats are in a
bad place and the republicans are in a
very good one which is why you see uh
president trump is very eager to get
back in the race i think he will i wrote
a uh i wrote a piece the case for donald
trump and the case against donald trump
in town hall and uh the president sent
me a nice note on a printout of the case
against donald trump that said you're
going to be very happy with what i do i
will not let you down okay
oh yeah i'm running but then we've also
got uh ron desantis who is outstanding
um
i i i'm looking forward to a powerful
republican primary where we really
figure out who the best guy is and the
uh voters of the republican party
uh decide who to go with because 24 is a
huge opportunity i think i i think our
win is uh
uh very very likely unless we do some
insane like you know nominate girl jeb
uh nikki haley
i happen to like nikki but i i know a
certain amount of the bass doesn't
digger uh but chad all right so let's i
think we're all in agreement on newsome
and you know this i don't know if you
saw the ad where he's you know going
after florida and going after desantis
and it's like literally every word is a
lie and that he dares even say the word
freedom is so extraordinary but let's
just back up to what kurt said there the
the trump desantis thing that's really
the thing that now is on everyone's mind
you know having gotten to know governor
defense a little bit i don't know that
he's going to run for president but i
know he loves florida this guy lives and
breathes this state um do you have a
preference and do you think there's one
that that works better than the other or
do you think they can have a meeting a
closed-door meeting and work this thing
out
if it's
look i don't i don't know if donald
trump's ego allows that to happen i i
would hope so that maybe there is some
you know tinge of humility left inside
there i don't know if it's ever existed
uh i i would hope so you know i think
that trump is sitting in a legacy
position where he really could be
a god maker uh in many ways to be the
neck that turns the head and pull a lot
of you know pull a lot of um people into
play that could be major game changers
without the rhetoric and the necessary
attacks by the the media towards a
donald trump if he was the actual guy in
charge now i'll take trump 10 000 times
over this [ __ ] nightmare we're
living right now
uh but i do hold out hopes that a guy
like ron desantis who who not only has
had good policy and good convictions who
loves his state he loves his job
but a guy who has been able to pull that
separation further apart between between
the leftist and right-wing ideologies
and show some real common sense and i
think right now it's not about political
parties look i say it all the time i
don't care if you have an r or a d by
your name if you're a big government
person you're garbage you're you're
human waste though you're the enemy of
the american people and i don't see ron
desantis as being that and uh i would
love to i would love to see how that
plays out on the national level yeah i
think you're especially right about the
fight that america needs to have that's
what i've been saying on the show lately
it's like the fight that and again i'm
with you i would vote for trump over any
of those guys i like the president i
think he's a good guy the media did
horrible things big tech did horrible
things but the fight that america needs
to have in some ways is the newsom
desantis fight it is the cali florida
fight like that's the thing that we all
have to hash out in front of us rather
than okay let's do a hillary uh trump
thing again or abide in trump thing
again or something like that but i i get
the people that are like he's still the
only one that can ram right through
kurt i'm going to give you the last word
because i believe you have a book and
maybe it's even in your lap right now
and something and chad if you want to
show your dog you can do that too but
kurt why should people buy this book
well first of all i talk about the trump
desantis issue the last two chapters the
second last chapter is about the 2024
election and my my thesis is look
we need to have a fight within the
republican party it doesn't have to be a
hostile fight it has to be a debate uh
you know the president has some good
reasons to run and he's got some
weaknesses
ron desantis has a lot of good reasons
to run
i haven't seen a lot of weaknesses yet
but that's why you have a primary so so
you can test these candidates sharpen
them hone them get them ready the last
chapter of my book which i'll raise
again will be back the pawn rise of
america is actually a president looking
back after eight years and how he fixed
america how he went and got the military
back on track how he got uh the the
proper role of the legislature and the
judiciary and the executive on track and
it's uh you know it's kind of funny it's
kind of exciting
uh i'm pretty happy with him people seem
to like it but look we we've got a big
fight against
ahead of us we've got to have the best
candidate and the way we do that is by
having a vigorous debate among a bunch
of candidates to say this is why i bring
to the table uh and let me uh answer
questions about my weaknesses so i'm i'm
looking forward to 22 i'm looking
forward to 2024.
we will be back literally we're going to
win
we can't lose to these goofs i said i
was going to give kurt the final word
but i know my audience well enough to
know that they want to see the dog again
chad show them the dog tell them why
they should adopt animals and then i'm
sending you guys on your way
there's biscuit
all right i thank biscuit i thank chad i
thank kurt kurt i'll see you next week
at the sunshine summit with that ron
desantis guy maybe he'll give us some
hints we shall i'm looking forward to it
i'll see you there and i'm bringing the
beautiful
breakfast taco that is my lieutenant's
wife whose ass is normal size by the way
i'll be the judge of that
all right guys have a good weekend i'm
gonna finish up solo for just a moment
thanks guys
all right people i think that was a nice
way to end the week by the way in case
you missed it i don't know if you heard
me promoting it for the last two months
but we had an absolutely fantastic show
in miami last night we had ron desantis
press secretary christina pusha and lisa
booth join me and dave roboy and it was
just a great packed crowd great energy
we did a live reuben report uh i did i
told the audience how many new
floridians and i would say about what do
you guys think about 20 were kind of new
floridians like last year or two
floridians and and then i said how many
of you you know born and bred old-time
floridians and i would say it was about
maybe 60
of the crowd and it was just such a
beautiful moment of you're not going to
believe this guys there were black
people there were gay people there were
straight people white people asian
people latino people i met a couple from
saudi arabia it was it was what it's all
about
so i hope that wherever you are you're
doing a little something that's what
it's all about which is that nobody
cares about your genitals or your skin
color they only care if you're a decent
person i hope with that in mind you'll
have a great weekend uh i don't know if
you heard some banging during the show
but we're almost done with the
construction here i am going to do
absolutely nothing this weekend because
i've got a baby on the way we've got a
baby on the way in a couple weeks and
i'm told that i'm running out of
weekends so i'm going to sit at a quiet
room with the dim light and stare at the
wall because i guess my days of doing
that are numbered anyway thanks for
playing along everybody and we'll see
you on monday